hi my name is Terry Andrus I am playing
Ariana in limelight okay and Terry how
did you get the role of Ariana and
limelight the casting director had just
casted me in something and asked me to
put this on tape and I actually
auditioned for Mia and then got Ariana
oh okay so different role and then you
were pleasantly surprised with part okay
and what do you think of today's social
media landscape I know the subject of
the film is a character who's an actor
and you know narcissism and and that
constant self-promotion but it seems
like it's a necessary I don't want to
call you evil
yeah but if there's there's good and bad
to it so what are your thoughts on it
because as an actress I'm sure that you
have a lot of things you have to do in
that realm as well tweet and Instagram I
think it's real I think it's hard it's
hard to have to promote yourself as the
product over and over and I think when I
think one of the big things is people do
get very much so
almost narcissistic or in their heads
about it which is it's a hard thing to
make somebody try to make themselves
sound like the best product and the best
thing the best person that they could
possibly be and like try to sell
themselves over and over and not not
become big-headed I guess or at least
look like it I mean I've lived in LA for
six-and-a-half years and for sure
you see people fall into that evil into
becoming so self-involved or evolving
into someone they're not because they
think it betters themselves in any which
way I know it's LA I feel like or
Hollywood you lose yourself very easily
people well it's interesting because you
were telling me you're from Northern
California I'm from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania and then I had a house in
Northern California as well so I grew up
split it was back and forth my whole
life okay and yeah Northern California
and Pittsburgh are very different than
Southern California but but it sounds
like both those places are more
down-to-earth probably in a lot of ways
what was that transition like you said
you've been here six or seven years yeah
six and a half must have been almost
like culture shock in some way or maybe
not I I traveled a lot growing up and I
was always into acting and everything in
the arts but it was I think like
decisions I made when I first moved out
here and like my view on everything when
I first moved out here is incredibly
different now hmm how so um I think I
was way more naive when I first moved
here which is funny with the storyline
and the character is like you you get
here you're almost on a high you're
excited and everyone you meet it's
really interesting and everyone's so
unique and has so much to offer and then
you I don't know for me I realized that
because I was very lonely very fast here
and like I am very trusting so for me I
guess meeting everyone here and learning
slowly how much people lie and fake and
how many people are actors and like in
their full-time life 24/7 so it is I
think I love the business I'm still
doing it but you also learn how to get
like a million walls up and learn how to
filter out as well as you can what's
real and what's fake and who's using you
and who's not and he's lying he's
telling the truth it's it's a learning
process and I think everyone's going
through it and it's a scary place
because it's a lot of big fish from
small towns coming in here so looking
back on before you came down here do you
think there's anything that could have
prepared you for that or it's just the
sort of thing where you have to go
through it I think no matter what you
have to go through it I think even when
you grow up in it because of I mean I
grew up with it around me my entire life
but whenever you're on your own I think
no matter what business or what anything
you go into when you're 18 and you're
all by yourself and you have your own
place near like I'm an adult you fall
flat on your face like a thousand times
kinds of you realize but you didn't
listen to what people were telling you
you have to go through it who's your
character in the film in limelight what
does she like arianna and she is kind of
the worst of them all she's an actress
slash model and I guess a
she's just I didn't she she dates three
guys
very much so into drugs she she does
whatever producers say she's kind of
lost completely she she thinks that if
she does everything that had producer or
that someone higher up once then she'll
end up being successful and I don't see
her ever becoming so I think she just
follows deeper and deeper into habits
that are hard to break and yeah she's
she's just a very scandalous um lost
girl I think and the archetype of
Arianna is common and maybe all of us
have that partners to some degree
meanwhile part whatever what advice
would you give to a real-life Arianna
let's say there was someone that came
from a small town like most people do
and had become that not everybody takes
that route but it was that heightened
version of that archetype what would you
say I'd say yeah if you're doing if
everything you're doing feels very wrong
then it's probably wrong like the
business is a business and it's yeah
it's got dark sides but if everything
you're doing is just manipulating and
especially with actors actors they you
can sleep with as many as you want I
don't think they're ever gonna get you
anything and with producers if they want
you in something they're gonna work with
you professionally they're not going to
you out which my character is
pretty much being out for
everything and especially she gets so
lost into addiction and drugs and that
won't help you in any business
acting modeling anything if you're doing
drugs it's only a slippery slope so
everything Arianna is pretty negative so
um and then I'd say try to keep as
professional as possible we'll try to be
true to yourself and it's a scary City
because of you do you do feel cut down
so many young beautiful girls move out
here and they instantly get plastic
surgery or change this about themselves
and that about themselves and they lose
themselves and they try to they try to
find their self-worth and somebody else
and you can't and they try to become
somebody else and that makes you less
unique than anything
so I'd say anyone that's in Ariana's
shoes needs to take a step back and be
who they are and stay away from pretty
much any type of drugs late night things
producers promising you things like at
3:00 in the mornings probably not true I
don't know it's a hard question there's
so I could talk for hours to an ariana
and like pray to God that she would not
do what she does why say yes to this
role even though there are many Ariana's
here would entreat you buy it and why
say yes to it and I think any actress
wants to do the down and gritty likes
it's a hard role and it's a fun rule you
get to do things that you wouldn't
normally do and also it's with this
movie I feel like it speaks a lot of
dark truth like it talks about because
he loses his brother and it's shocking
like he's there one day and he's
actually just gone the next
very honest from a drug overdose and his
little brother never did drugs but he
just got caught up in it and my
character sadly is one of the ones that
got him to do the drugs because he
overdosed on coke and and I think
Arianna is very real and a lot of people
and I think seeing it sometimes on
screen or seeing the reality of it it
does help people or it kind of like
helps people maybe relate to it in their
life
and for me I up with like that type of
stuff around me drugs or whatever and I
never I've never done any so it's
interesting for me to try to dip into
what I've seen and they try to relate to
it and I lost my brother to drugs and so
when I read the script
and he loses his brother to drugs and
it's exactly like that it's you don't
expect it and and my brother lost it to
a girl pretty much was a very like
seductive woman she was doing it all the
time she got him to try it and he did
the same amount overdosed died and
that's what my character and the other
girl in it pretty much do we seduced him
he thinks it's awesome and he passes and
a lot of people think that they can try
it once and
be fine or just see what it's like and
that's not true
I mean it's no matter what dangerous so
I wanted to play this part for the fun
the layers and just someone has to oh I
hope I represent her well enough that
I don't know the devil's supposed to be
beautiful and seductive and in LA you
find a lot of that type of evil where it
seems wonderful and it seems beautiful
and perfect and you're just getting
dragged down deeper and deeper and
deeper and it was an interesting part
for me to play do you think it was
almost meant to be in some ways yeah I
think I think there's way too many
people trying to work in this business
that if you get something it's probably
meant to be it's such a not a gamble
because you work your butt off to get it
but yeah I think I think anything that
happens is meant to me going back to the
social media aspect of the film how much
do you feel a pressure to promote
yourself on different platforms and then
how much of your own need to kind of be
true to things it sounds like you have a
real need for that and that's great that
you really want to stay true to yourself
and to the things that are around you
how much of that plays into what you do
on social media because it's a weird
thing with it yeah no it is it's really
weird and when I first had moved to LA I
had Twitter and all of that and link was
very into Twitter and two weeks ago I
did an interview on a new show called
truth and they asked me to tweet and
Isaac I haven't tweeted in a couple
years and the producer looked and was
like you actually haven't tweeted it
like in a couple years and I was like
yeah and so I had to like redo my
password and sign in and like tweet
about this show and now I'm tweeting
because I found out my managers say that
booking you don't you don't book as many
jobs if you don't have that many
followers because they want your fanbase
to bring in to the show or film or
anything so it puts a certain pressure
on you to be interesting
where I'm at I'm a single mom and my day
is pretty much me and my son was hanging
out and he's won so I really I'm not
that interesting
at all anymore I'm usually just playing
with my son changing diapers and seeing
my friends whenever I can but now I have
to on social media be like oh crap I am
working like I am filming right now I
have to like post and it's a sea thing
like I that is that's a weird sure to
try to make my life look any type of
fabulous which I don't know I mean I
guess it is fun it's fun filming it's
fun to take pictures and like I have a
terrible memory so I guess it's good for
me to look back at anything that I
posted in the past and be like oh I
forgot all about this and doing this and
doing that so now for me it's almost
like online I'm using it more of like a
diary a public diary where like my son's
first steps are on it is like first
little sentence
I don't know holidays filming all of
that stuff has become public and and
yeah it's it's strange to try to word it
and make it interesting for other people
because of to me it's my entire world so
it's interesting to me but I don't know
how to portray it to others and I hope
I'm doing it in an honest good way and
that people are interested in it what if
your son wants to be an actor
that's fine he's growing up in LA so
that's good yeah there's both of his
father and I met on Days of Our Lives
playing boyfriend-girlfriend so he was
created through the arts totally fine if
he wants to do the arts whatever he
wants to do I'm a big believer you can
play every sport do every instrument
whoever
dance anything and you can go to
chemists camp science camp you can do
any of it I don't care since both of his
parents are artists I almost feel like
he's gonna end up being like a doctor
her lawyer where me and the dad are
gonna make we can't help you with your
homework because we don't know so yeah
my parents support me and love me and
help me in my dream so I can only hope
to be half as good as them with my son
what advice would you give him let's
suppose he's old enough to understand I
know you say he's one now but let's
suppose at 18 he decides he wants to
start acting what advice would you give
him in terms of I'd say keeping it real
yeah I'd say keep your family the
closest because for me that's what keeps
me alive I think having my family and
having that support I would say that
being in this business is 99% rejection
even after you make it or after you feel
like you have succeeded you're going to
have just as much negativity coming at
you as positivity for your whole life
and there's way too many people's
opinions coming at you and now I hope
that he'll have a thick skin and I hope
that he'll realize that the people
closest to him are all that matter and
that his opinion on himself is all that
matters and I hope that he stays true to
himself and true to what he thinks is
right and wrong and doesn't get
manipulated or scared or pressured into
going away that will only pull him down
I hope he's happy
can someone develop a thick skin let's
say they don't I mean most artists are
pretty sensitive yeah it makes them
great so can someone develop it I think
any artist gets rejected a lot more than
people and notice to say like you go to
auditions constantly in most of it's a
no and sometimes you get a yes but that
somebody is literally telling you like
no you're not good enough or you don't
look right or this is wrong with you or
this is wrong with you or like you just
don't fit or this person actually is
like the connection that you didn't like
weirdest things so I think for like yeah
I think you do just naturally started
developing a thicker skin or realizing
that it's out of your control and the
parts that are in your control is the
fact that you work hard you stay focused
you stay true to yourself you stay
healthy and you are the best and honest
you that you can be and if you do that
and at the end of the day if you were
rejected or not or if you book something
you at least know that you're you you're
happy with yourself and you did the best
that you could then everything else is
out of your control and I think that's
the only way to have a thick skin as an
artist is to just know that you're doing
you and that you are trying your best
and that you're bettering yourself in
every way I think I said earlier that
the character Arianna there's there's
like varying degrees of that person yeah
and probably all of us so
what do you think most people would see
in themselves with Arianna maybe they
wouldn't go as far as some of the things
that she's doing in the field but in
terms of like selling themselves doesn't
have to be sexually or with drugs but
there could be parts I mean that that we
all sort of sell ourselves yes well I
think everyone loses themselves in
things and it's hard it's hard for any
human to look in the mirror directly at
themselves and be honest with themselves
and with Arianna I think she looks in
the mirror and she's not honest at all I
think I think she's completely like I I
think she's lost herself but I can't
think of one person I know that hasn't
been completely lost at one point or
another so I think people can relate to
her mostly because sometimes you just
get caught up and you're gonna crowd or
a you're in a situation or you're in a
new life everyone that pretty much
leaves their parents and goes wherever
they go that's that's usually such a
different world wind whether you're in
an apartment down the street or you're
just in college or you're on the other
side of the country or the other side of
the world you're all of a sudden an
adult and you make your own decisions
and sometimes you make decisions and
it's not your opinion you're using other
people's because you're too afraid of
your own and you just keep doing that
and doing that and you're not honest
with yourself you can't even look at
yourself in the mirror and I think
everyone has a point where they break
and they're like I don't know who I am
like I feel like 80 year old people can
still look in the mirror be like I don't
know who I am yeah I don't know I don't
know what happened I don't know where I
went wrong I don't know what I missed
but everyone has regrets and as a young
adult in a whirlwind of new experiences
I think everyone can say the
they've made horrible mistakes that they
wouldn't want to admit to and that a lot
of people instead of apologizing to
themselves or to whoever and moving
forward and trying to do a clean slate a
lot of people make the mistake of
denying denying and going deeper and
deeper and getting darker and darker
because they don't want to admit the
truth because right when they do that's
the hardest part is realizing that you
are not perfect or that you messed up
and I think a lot I think Arianna is
Arianna is a troubled soul and I think
everyone is so I think in many ways
people can relate to her in any step of
life you just you start lying to
yourself because it's easier so it's
about what 3 in the morning right yeah
we're doing this interview and it's
great because it's very raw and very
real and yeah I like that what's next
for you I know you're going to be
wrapped on this project on limelight
yeah and again getting some sleep and
it'll be back to normal but what's next
for you after this or are you in a state
of not knowing just yet and you like
that or I'm leaving for Paris in England
from one of my best friend's weddings
oh wow in two weeks for two weeks and
I'm leaving my son for the first time
I've never been away from him for like
more than 24 hours so that is really
hard and and then I'm coming back and I
booked the part of Pocahontas in a new
TV series called the colony and we're
filming October through November Wow so
that'll be fun yeah initially first like
lead on a show so that'll be
overwhelming and exciting but yeah okay
so lots of so far that's a lot of things
big things I've been trying to figure
out a nanny
for my child that's actually my number
one thought mmm
trying to figure out that but that's
what's next in Polk honest is definitely
gonna be very different than Ariana
right for acting classes Terry what what
do you consider being active I know they
always say the actors should continue
yeah well I grew up I grew up in act one
theater which was a school and enough
after-school program and then PTP
professional theater program through
high school every day after school and
where we'd study a history of film we'd
do we'd put on different plays musicals
and then when I moved out here I got
connected with Dennis LaBelle
he's an amazing acting coach and I
worked with Jocelyn Jones I always go
back to Dennis because I feel like he's
like my uncle but I I take private
lessons from him and I take his acting
class and I pretty much I try to put up
scenes and work on characters that I
don't usually get booked as so or like
things I wish like dream characters you
know or something but I wish I could do
I put those in class and would a
Shakespeare work hard on monologues just
I think as an actor I know a lot of
actors when they start professionally
working they'll stop practicing in class
but you have so much time off or at
least I have so much time off that I
think it's like any other thing it's not
like riding a bike I think you get rusty
it's like playing an instrument or
singing or playing a sport you have to
keep practicing you have to keep being
open to new characters and working on it
so I'm a huge believer no matter where
you are in your success that you should
always be sharpening that tool what are
the characters that you want to play
that you haven't or that you don't
usually get to like what what are those
roles growing up I always played boys
and always
medic parts like old ladies because I
did I did theater so I always played
really big comedic characters and in
film I always play kind of like
Ariana's like I a a lot of more
scandalous women and so in class I like
to still visit comedy and I try to bring
comedy out and other things and then I
also my scariest thing is probably
actually super dramatic and crying and
tearing down all those walls and being
like just super vulnerable so I'm trying
really hard to bring more gentle soft
weaker characters out that I guess
you're not weak you're honestly the
bravest if you're okay with being
vulnerable and open in front of people
so for me I think the hardest characters
when we are definitely the ones that
have really gone through trauma and that
are showing all their wounds it's my
least favorite thing to play so that's
why I had to keep working on it until I
loved it I have to be okay with it
what's the most interesting piece of
feedback someone's ever given you a
director or agent casting director it
could be positive negative but it always
stuck with you at time
I know there's probably something way
better than or deeper than this but I I
went from doing theater my whole life to
film and I think my biggest thing going
to camera from stage was they're like
you have you actually like you have to
be real and I was like I am real like
I'm feeling this and they're like yeah
but you have to bring it down and you
have to understand that every twitch
every move every hair is seen on camera
it's right here so you don't have to do
this you just have to be real so
whatever you're feeling they'll see it
in your eyes like you don't you don't
have to make it this huge dramatic
process you can just pretty much bring
everything down and see his human and as
natural as possible and I always I grew
up acting in thinking that I was being
that and I was I just knew how to
portray it huge so one of my first
directors taught me it too I guess that
just literally realized that you don't
have to be doing these huge gestures and
stagg leaps across the stage to show an
emotion you can shrink it down to show
it with your soul and with your eyes I
like that
shrink it down that's good which is I
think what anyone that ever did theater
and switch to film probably got the
exact same I'm pretty sure but yeah that
was that one sticks with me because to
this day I'm like that the camera the
cameras right here I hope they remember
that they don't yeah they don't need
they don't need stag leaps across the
stage anymore
Terry how do you know when you're
hitting your mark with a character or a
scene I don't I don't I mean I think I
think I can feel if I'm being honest
with the character and trying to portray
what I want to try but you can think
you're doing an incredible job and be
completely off your mark I don't know I
I am one of the people that I usually
can't even watch my work and it's scary
it's
it's for me I I'll do the best I can and
I guess the advice I gave my son is the
advice I'll give to myself just I'll do
the best that I can and I can hope and
pray that I hit the mark but I don't I
can never say if I actually know if I
did especially in film whenever there's
so many takes and so many everything's I
can only hope be true and honest with
myself with the work that I'm doing and
hope it's great what is that about not
being able to watch yourself or even
some people here themselves accordingly
that's so straight I know and I hear
that from so many people yes I don't
know I think it's I think it's true for
a lot of people because if you watch
yourself you watch anything you didn't
you're like oh I should have done this
or like even when you're done you you'll
your character will evolve
way after you haven't filmed it and
you're like mmm I wish that I had this
or like you hear somebody say something
you're like oh I wish I knew that before
I like just no matter what I feel like
for me I've never I never have seen
something I've done and been like yep
that's it that's perfect I'm great I am
always like oh I wish I didn't do this I
wish I didn't do that or I wish I I got
myself to this point you're your
toughest critic
I don't know I don't know whenever I've
hit my mark
it's it's scary so you try not to watch
yourself that's why I take classes is
because I'll I'll force myself to watch
myself I'll force myself to and I will
always listen to every opinion and get
every direction that I can and but
whenever it's the finished product and I
know I can't change it or fix it or help
with it yeah it's print worthy because
if you always wish that you did
something different maybe not maybe
that's just where I am in my career in
fact I know that I have a lot of growing
to do I've heard that from other people
as well and I've always been shocked
from from my point of view seeing them
wondering why that would be but yeah
it's I'm hearing that as a common yeah
but you will force yourself at some
point yeah and I mean I'll watch I'll
watch it is not I hope ever I hope the
audience is happier than I think I'll
say you know every single detail that
you put into it and you know like your
yeah you know what you hope to portray
and obviously if you don't give a
hundred and ten percent of what you were
imagining that it's gonna be a
disappointment in yourself or for
yourself which is horrible it's a
horrible thing to say is your I don't
know I think no matter what you're in
you're your toughest critic usually are
you competitive
and um I'm more if I'm in an argument
I'm totally the person was like oh
you're okay okay okay sorry I'm a huge
apology I apologize about everything all
the time like sorry sorry um I played
sports growing up and no I think like if
I saw somebody else even when I score
goal better than me or want to do
anything like get past me or something
it's like no no I think what pushover I
just I feel bad instantly and I'm not
competitive which is a very weird
business for me to be in but I think as
an actress you're only competing against
yourself what if someone's competitive
toward you you're not bringing it to
them but you can sense it and we've all
been in those situations yeah that's
that's fine I think that comes from
their own insecurities whenever like if
I'm in an audition room and I know
people are trying to take people that it
doesn't it doesn't do anything it
doesn't mean anything because they
should be focusing on their craft and
focusing on studying in their character
or just like relaxing and not trying to
psych other people that just shows that
that they're not happy with themselves
so I don't pay any energy to it
otherwise it'll just take me out of it
anyway Sam it means nothing
happiest moment as an actor uh-huh
I booked a part name Queenie in the
musical hunk and it was my first like
girly character ever and it was my first
solo songs and all of this stuff and it
was it was a junior high performance and
I just I like bawled my eyes out because
I was so excited because I always played
a bunch of characters in each show and
like smaller parts and everything
and I remember that's the only part I
wanted and I wanted it so bad
and it was my first big success I liked
it for me it was a tiny little like
local play and I died that that I got
the part that I dropped to have like I
was auditioning for it I was in my
theater school I wanted this character
and I got it and I was excited because
of you and you know you're you're going
through puberty you don't know if you're
pretty you're really insecure and you're
trying your hardest to fit in in anyway
and I I got to play the princess I got
to play the part that I wanted and that
was the first time that I had that and
they went home and told my dad in music
so you're not an oompa loompa you're not
a tree heatedly Queenie and I was
exciting it's exciting to know that
you're like you know I worked really
hard and it was my dream and it came
true and it's exciting as an actress for
any any booking and that was my first
one that that's that's what I wanted
Thanks I didn't want any character more
I wanted that one so yeah I think that
was my master setting and obviously you
know I've had other job since but it's
always it's the first one yeah Queeny
Queeny do you feel like this is what you
were meant to do being actors or is
there any other thing I mean I know
you're a mom so that's probably changes
so much of your worldview but up until
that point maybe did you feel that that
acting is is the only thing for you yeah
I started acting since before I can
remember just with I have four older
siblings and we all put on plays and did
all of that growing up and entertained
and I grew up dancing since preschool
and singing and grew up in musical
theater and I just
no matter I played sports and I did good
in school but nothing made me excited
like the arts and like acting and I'm
not that great of a singer and I yeah I
just naturally I guess I have always
gone back to acting and it's a
therapeutic thing for me it's it's a
wonderful thing to be able to step into
somebody else and bring your honest
opinion out into someone that lived a
different life like you you get handed
this character this human that you've
never met before and you read about them
and you have to try to show them and
create and be this person that you
didn't live that life but everyone can
relate to everyone in some way or
another and it's all about trying to
bring that to life pretty much it's
putting yourself in somebody else's
shoes and trying to make it as real and
as honest for yourself
and I love I love that and I've lived
like that my entire life any time I'm
talking to anybody I try to truly
understand and feel what they're feeling
and you know be human so the character
it's for me it's really fun it's it's
fun homework and it's fun putting it on
and it's fun
living in their skin and it's exhausting